こんにちははじめ社長ですそういうわけで
始まりました大場が君には騙されるわけが
ないエピソード1でございます
はいというわけですね恋愛といったらこの
人でしょうエピスペシャルゲストです
こちらのパパにお越しいただいております
すみ趣味ですよろしくお願いします
ti よろしはロッドたち
ブーバー&
ross ちょっと記憶していってはいと
で今回のでどういう奇策かといいますと
あの僕
恋愛番組を通してもやらせたい後輩がい
ましてですね
始め者とじっとり方知ってるんですけども
同省後でバカを今回4人集めました
内容としては僕の後編の墓よりんと美女を
1人僕の新居に投入して4ちょっと5人で
生活してもらおうかなという大いいですね
やっておりますはい今回ですねあれば50
年記年で私はじめ移設をアンバサダーに
就任致しておりましてパパさんはグレーだ
と一緒に阿部真央盛り上げていっており
ます会うの入って全開なんですけども藤川
球児さんとですね野球企画を去って
いただいたりしたんですけども今回も阿部
ば球場荘プロジェクトとしてニューヨーク
さんが mc のニューヨーク恋愛市場と
のコラボになりまなるほどあはい
ネギさん初回でられるそうです初回ゲスト
に呼んでいただきました結構今までにない
ぐらい恋愛の話を掘り下げてくれる番組で
するのアイドル卒業後なくそういう話は
あまりすることがなかったのでドキドキし
つつも結構ニューヨークさんとの距離も
近く
いや位と話してメダ男女ともに乱獲を恋愛
かでズレとかあるじゃんあるんだよえ夫
見せてそうなんだ同じてそうなんだって
いうものでも楽しみながらトークをしたり
する番組だったので今日とかもなんだな
始めた上男性ではで修正意見とかぜってー
違うと思うから確かにそういう意味では
心配であり楽しめそうですよねじゃあ
そもそもそれが成り立つかどうかんっを8
人がかかってるんですけどわかりますよね
そして今回はですね番組内で紹介された
これらの ba テクニックが書かれた
カードを崩してもらってですねぜひとも
美女のバカたちに落としていただきたいと
ておりますに服に行くちゃいいですね本当
は真っ向に行くの本当に苦しいと思うんだ
よねちょっと意欲体目でカーを投入したい
かなと
ケンケンできますかね
[音楽]
ネジブツブツと最初だけやろそして命中
できるっていう感じで pearls よ
そんなバカ立つでも恋愛テクニックを
すっかり磨けば美女を落とせるのではない
かということでさっそく見ていきましょう
ウェディあるどうぞ
あのそうでしょ
どうぞ
つまりますちょっと多分峯岸さん誰が誰だ
かわかんないと思うちょっと紹介させて
いただくと思う本日お口です
いきました
勾配の巣だと言う
ハイスタさん砂辺してという感じです
これはの会社員で働いてい
本日ぐらいですムース20
12時ついちゃんくらい深いんだ
が ap サーベという思いですね
それが今21です
一番若い
木一番ふっからです
音楽迫ってるからっ
服装の大豆ですよそうです
ています心配になるわけですね
雨が動きたいと言う
結構距離年上ですいい
voodoo
marいやいやネガティブな部分ます
タイプのお財布です
しっかりデー
数で割るいいえ3 e 4 e 2
には
福関係
んじゃないですかありますねえええええ
いつもあるからそれ
大学が着飾らないんでありうるか白山市で
つけばいいわけです
k 作った
ええええええ
結構動画展望やりましょうかくれる後輩
です
立地論なんかなっても見せファンです
ボトム場です
差額ちょっと
者になるしかあります
voodoo
これではフード来たらどんな改善打つと
普通
いけません
クリスマスっている
やった指すぐの世情フィードいます
っていう仕事は1基
すっげえ
ペイズリー
翻しです
いい
こんにちは私だなあああ
あ4
そして6本の bj
て言ってくれ
ない真ん中しかないの
これは約10分
視聴してねそうですねございません
前世
破ってさや
早いんじゃ
[音楽]
[拍手]
あじゃあじゃん
くださはい日ジュースウォッチさーんつく
です県警
はいそう service さん
お願いします
belarusてねー
これでいいと思いますとかそれでも決定
23体でえっ甘いほしいはい4
しまうんですね
えっ
石塚こと俺よ本当に
212色は辛いっ
usao
[音楽]
デーってはい
フレッシュ
31ですちゃん父いい
初期使っています
1の授業できるんです
逆に動作し年下とか私は言いますがさせに
なりますけどずれない
en優しいねme
悪い安いからん
ケース径はコミュ力あるべきだろう
[音楽]
過払いに
話しています八野紘
もっといいなしかしあるわけでは全員音楽
シーンですけどと一発芸してもらうなあー
learn
あれねええ
2つの基本本当に自分の中で一番いいと
思ってる奴本当にもそれ
いきますよ
ちょっと話たちがすげー落ち着いて来
なかったいやいいんですけどすごい一番
ええんじょ
いやー面白いとかあるんですか
3なんか好きなはキックボックスです
yeahirb 亡くしたやってるんです
ね
すごい数字と比べてやってましょうん
レース後からてやってると
キックボクシングところもない
ame
ツボ巣ね
まあでも今も全然みんな一つけどなぁと
思いますよちょっとも助けたい
春暖と思ってるだけですかね
付で男性というところ
聞く
キロちょっとねよな
得られる
整理買いなんですよねか私したでも c で
もかけられ件だけどね中9
すぐは無理ですか
ちょっと手の込んだよやってるんですねー
ほんと志向から一緒にねぇああそうですね
俊英の俺
えっ
もう身長とかとしているてっきりしない
です船長も全然関係ないよ手術ホイス六社
神社高いんですよ
キュッとナージャ
力は列車が桜と趣味
ブーバー
しよ
10分で着きなんだけど
まだよ
でもなんかみんななく中にやってる感じだ
から
背伸びしすぎも服装はいえばがっめっちゃ
う
自然も設置していへぇねべ adele は
まずない
まにゃんだろうカラヤンてやさせたいけば
いいん
ビックリッキーな福造たくありません感じ
えっパターするあかーんパーカーっと
膝下ぐらいもだからスカートみたいなああ
ああせデイジイ
です次カーみたいな感じが噓ずカジュアル
な感じが好きです
そうですかっ
児玉に良いはないですよね楠岡見た目より
某
代弁で続きですうーん
間に合ってる女の子が使ったあるいは書い
ておけます
やってる場所もやってい
服着てくれればそれでません
うんいいと思います
ran何があってアゾ嵐を持ってい
ということで
手一杯です予定です私くって
02まあ
パーシーください
おいしいね面白い
うーんやっぱりですね
さてだぜ
今ならサブプリってくれてますね
振ってるー
されていますまた系終わりのないんです
けど全然
の人たちです
俺6
クッキーでボックス付きません
全然大丈夫れいったん戻ってきます
いい
c 味かと思っています
ではではっ
ニックって
これ
par
ませんして重いいよっ say
refer
where
ところが一度の乾杯前の研究室
その場合じゃないんで出ると乾杯を入れる
ことをそっと要求じゃないです
日本茶な一番予定です
一番いい気です
ユーキャンなのです
禁ずでとってば堤ヲタじゃないですねそれ
があったんです
携帯ですます
コンパイルはい
なぁ
ええええええ
三次
今回
卒
じゃあ質なカスん
ゲームを落とします遊びませんね料金は
一般が良くて余計にいっぱい多分
したせましたつけましょうです
すごくるこちらへ
多分
ああぜひ
左がある
えっ
ありがとうございます
これ分ん
はいということでございましたーーー
はいはい
まあまあファースト魂魄最初でもこんな
もんですようわ覚えましたようんしたら
なんか耳にしたんでにこの人のこれは気に
なったなみたいなのがありましたええけん
すけさんがやっぱり社長も言ってた通りず
寝ちゃベリーがいい感じで肩の力抜き入っ
てて大臣賞一番モテそうだなぁと思いや
そうなんですよデカイですよね彼がいない
とちょっともう怖いん
あと須田ちゃんすごい君つは最初
ファッション気になったんですよなんか
笑顔とキャラが強いなんか可愛くて
キャラクターぽく見えてきては遠いけど
なんか愛着が変わります方はいらっしゃい
ますかございましたちょっとまだ子って
なんかサーフではあんまり
ちょっとダッセージったしきれてないと
いうそうですよねちょっまだまだまだこれ
からだろうなと思ったらちょっとまた外部
化たいんですけどもまぁさっすぐ僕は
ずっと見てて不安になってしまいましたね
もうずっとも次早速
恋のテクニックカードを買いたいと思い
ます
使いこなせるかな
リーはちょっとタイミングとかやっぱ
テクニックも必要だと思うけどそれは
何かのヒントになればいいから星かに思い
まして動かしたいちょっと好カードを伏せ
て選んで聞いたカードにそれぞれ違う
テクニック書いてあるのでそれを是非とも
4人に実践してもらいたいと思います
まあそうで本当にあの女の子らしくて
あの
7話やせください月に観覧影しますので
そうですねぇー
結構好きになる子がだいたい身長高いぷな
ので
ちょっとタイプですルー
i love you
そうやって日々
大声で温めがまあん
家を[ __ ]で運営テクニックのカードが今
はコレ
さらにあったやつ弾けると一枚ですけど
これが ksk の指令ですねちますさあ
をちょっと踏み込んだことを聞いていい
ってから好きな色はといえれない
ええなんでモテると思ったくださを知るか
さ
どこがいいんだろうけど笑っちゃいそう
ですよねああいったと構えさせてカラー
トナーに沿ってみたいなんでそんなことか
行くそうですよねそういう日が和むの花
っぽい気がしますね
良さそう
マジでねー悦じゃん思われないですああ
そうですねだけ網膜か言い方とかでだいぶ
左右されそうな気がするちょっと梅が問わ
れそうですね先生が大事だ
しましょう
ああ
俺私があの番組に出た時にお話しした
エピソードなんですけど芸人さんも bkb
さんですかよ共演したときに誰にも私は
呼ばれたことなかったんですけどを見
netter なのでを見ぬフェリーれて
みーちゃんとかそりーちゃんと何だかそう
いう呼ばれ方の大嶺ってば付けてっ
誰も寄ってないんだけどなんで急にみたい
な
売れしかってます嬉しかったんですか変
ですか
あ夫は高校のとき母だっ休暇嵯峨野なんで
はエマは肇社長はじめとか喘いだ
paddy 知らないあんまり仲良くない
女の子にあっちゃんって呼ばれるて
くださいちょっと感想いたんですけど
ちょっと
一方あァ
なんかちょっと待っ何
うんちょっと特別感ってくだり感想良いの
これ
がんばリスナー余って流行に疲れた c
そして次がサーベイのスレですね yeah
ファンの人が抱くネイティブイメージを
否定するのは有効でも番組内でくれりゃ
どういうことです
めちゃくちゃ俺女好きなんだよねって言っ
た人に
それを否定するという
そっか女の子の立場になってちょっとダメ
な音殺せとかああいうの良くないよねって
ちょっと女の子の味方的立ち位置を使う見
ないのところなんですちょっとさは馬鹿な
んでも分かったりとかでかちょっとう
ティム高等テクニックそうですね不できる
かなちょっと怖いところはで撮っただけで
これ
がんばれ
ムコスタ停止て by kenichi ね
あのひとつ悪い話教えていればノートこの
人が下げろ
佐伯0
チャイけど僕がさせていただいてますって
みんな種類ありますかそれでええ
やっぱりほか起きようと酸っぱめ姉もこう
なんだよポカ置こうとして自分のピュー
そろそろアリかもしれないパンツ装備に
売ってるぞ
あまり
ごっつはよくつないかもしれないけど
儲からないともっと悪く見せるっていう姉
あてっる全体的にキャット下げるって言う
言われますよと思います
気になりますこれ
lost らしいこと書いてありました
まあなんか
こういう勝ち方もあるなんてこういう恋愛
でしたぞよ
んですね勉強になります一部じゃなくて
いいよなんか
学生にもいい
なく捨てません
いや逆になる子
こういう
ないから
[音楽]
ミット者顔ひきつってるせて
なぁ
に良い感じするこれはいい感じですアップ
潜って持ってあっをちょっとこれ
やっとするか
まあまあでオモロイっちゃおもろいを貰い
う8月のは面白そういう邪気に今までやっ
たことのないテクニックだなって感じなん
で
逐条的にあるのかもしれん ti
のゴム日常してい
あるさせる
4ばいばーい
天津ためちょっとサービス巡拝なぁ
一番パワー
をじっ間違えちゃってん
集約ですね死薬です感じでね
ちょっと裏ミッションで
沢辺にちょっと近づけられてみました
ああーーやゲーム前に良いのありかもなく
なってるんですよですか伊藤やべさやって
よく言われています車載ん
うちに男性の名前覚えています
5ぼっちですがっ人さん
釣られすだーさんたくさんつけますさて
ですがけん制です県付近が賄った先生も
お前が旅それ先生ですね
無水件はいっ
はいっ
えっこの大一番ですねぇー
自分を覚えやすいと思うウォッチですね
はいです
現在音です
じゃあなんかさえちゃ
あの知っていいトランプゲームあるそこ
さえ増産もゲームとか
あと版は抜き
awesome game hard プリ
プロ g ナビ付シンプルなゲーム4日中
です
周りさてずにぜひどうぞ
いこーどレジャーはされちゃうから聞き
ましょう
どっちから期待今設定
これと俺サード違って増加変えたいまあ逆
を選べない
ああああ
ああああああああああ
癒し看護ローって俺が敷かれる
祝って合うんですよ
そうです
今これ一緒になったら4 s はいその中
に出して
失火ボクシングのぐらいやってるんですよ
バックスイングは1年ぐらい長いですね高
お願い楽しいですい
母月短時間で米シーンきたいるからそれが
まあまあ共振のかよターン殴ってさあ
ちょいエロされ
蹴られたいです経営と言って買ったらけっ
てください雛4回以外はバレエ中で切って
くださいもう一回じゃないから
やる価値損はない宇宙それが1層をも白
ねぇベールアップ
うわあああっね
立っていてもいいですね
よくなりそういうするからそうでしょ対戦
ひどいん
山のそういうパンサーにしこれこの場が
できマジどうでもいいですね
で共同で見てくださいじゃねはい5月
とりあえず
センターそういうのって誰
どっちだと思います
あっ女0個0おおぉ
いいねミッション絵
コンテちゃってございます
ちょっと日本サイズ階でございますra
re
[音楽]
ブーバーします
プレスええええええ
4世うわぁ
210わぁし受講がが赤外します世界者は
過労
なんか逆に指定していただけです
そのとなり誰がいいんですa
決めて富士
鮭寸きゅんで活躍台ですねす暑いかがいい
子だと子育ていいのでしょうか
最初はゆったりっぽい
はいこれでしょ
それ
ニャー
ズニャうねえよくらいじゃないとください
ディスコアーク
でしっ
の悪い絶
ヒッポから100万7分1 k
ここで
もうこれ
ですねっ
あいずみさん慰安もうマリアのどこ行って
もらったこいつんe 0
きっしょまえあー
[拍手]
ブーブー
言っ3カー3アティ
moonゆったん
結構簡単ですあるキングが一番
強い
1が一番よわれ
見ないで見ないねぇ
寝ないでこのままつけるって言うのですね
はい次北行きますねはい
えっ
流行っちゃうんじゃないかいたという
ましてすべて絶対回答れるあやっちでた
穴場目に遭っても今日じゃ
ブーバー
しかーし
ブーブー一旦混ぜて野球の設定
pou
dou
douうん f します下がりなく一番2
外てすごい uhb leg
えっ
芝という国
知らなきゃいけないなええme
ん
良い縁とけばいいなと思うのです
をぜひ以上よ
ありません
はい避けるやつ
この良い子つけてもつながれましたね
ふわっあるしない方の歪みうまくかわし
たらじゃあ
方とはいい
入れ校
やれやれ
2たちになる
遺影
それ
はいオッケーです後0敗
もしそれじゃないかなっちゃったから
よろしいなあああああ
これら4 ae cn
それでしかに入りさせ
でっ
言わんでしょ
音ですね
うわあもう
じゃん
でごと使い方です
国も多い俺はい
まじかぁああああ
それ
それはれましたあけっこ5
やはり早いほうが高いのも嫌なんです
ますします
悪いんだから
を使いました私はああこれ
renarena
ああああザッハーん
pou dou
dou
[音楽]
voodoo
ブーバーし雲海アメリカじゃ寝ているし
やり方が入ってこういうことっん
輝く義母が訪ればいいだけねもうちょっと
ずつ生じる
裏も早いいいですもっとも階です
テコ入れ rar スレイの
いっ
うわぁ
俺
と一緒に
今なんですよ
ん
主てるから
感の解消薔薇せんすべてを見せる1いい
くらい
僕はより丈夫な誤植ねっこ宮城で
ありがとうございますこのできる
[音楽]
ぶー
ぶーっ
大
嬉しいブルー n
を知ってきたとき心配ないと思います
ran
いやだからそれを言っちゃぁああ
いや
の底を突くたち取り方
あっああああ程よいハリ
ね
とやりやすいと4座りましょう
ano ん
僕が良かったですかはい
もう存知ですかえっ
けみお
ねえよありがとうございません
せっかくスペシャルちょっと横に行っても
いいですかねぇ
なったんだよ
meだから小太りだなぁ
いえそれから売っ
ていそうですね
んじゃないかね設置はザッツんだ
5立っ
antec ニックは何度とピクニックス
カー
アジャなっている
ああそれ文化
6つか社員戦争優先し h と
アチェ市って思ったんですけど結果綺麗な
花の時もすべてブーブー
はこれは一般人がイラクに願ってぶー
なぁ
ものを否定したり有効でてみたいな感じ
だったんですよ
とりあえずめっちゃ簡単なくなった簡単
だったけど
よかったのがよくなかったかわかんない
けどなんかメッツ個別のしていいですか
って言ってなんか好きな色なんですか
ループやするだったからなあーいろんな男
ですでもなんかまあまあ面白がって聴いて
くれてるだからもうその風にいいのかなと
ぜひなくが
4位確かにね何が c ねサーベルキラー
明治ん
悔しいなぁ
悔しいですねめちゃ悔しい
ゼミナール自分から告白できたり
できます上でああ
にぎわった
pou
dou
dou何もう
はリングありなるあの
んだろ校
ね見れるん
えっ前でベビーずに想像してね見れないん
ですツーショットだけどいいですかこええ
いい
[音楽]
nars つ持ってくださる時間でござい
ますね時間が2ちょっとくん
後ろに極力をしよう
いきますね祝が伝わるといい
あえってはをの夫違いじゃん
映画を近く言います靴や踊れやせてくれば
良かったのに同じ人間とは思えないくらい
の差が
year
ん
ちょっとその後
pooh 3階テクニック使ってました
ねー
いやー
見受けられなかったなぁ
僕つの現場にいたんですね使ってなかった
です使ってないんだ
ムズかったかあの言葉も理解が出来て
なかったんですよねお母さんには傘に
難しかった母
うさんは一応
でブザーちゃんが猫って言って
ケンスケいるのではないですね下げたけど
健介さんの気がしうまかっなかったので猫
として勝ってくれって言ってたんだよね
ってなんだったらやっぱりいいかさてだ
なぁミニさあツーショットに乗ってるツー
ショットいや何かもゴッチさんがすごいて
れててカー2人きりぬ話すことがあんまり
ないけどそろそろスっていうのはなんか精
一杯なんだろうなぁと思って責めろ総監部
なかったなるほどなるほどねー若いでしょ
藪さん茶は仮ですね健介さんみたいなの
結構いいと思っちゃうああああちょっと
いいぐいとなんか慣れてるなぁ
まで楽しませてくれるなるんじゃなやり手
な男の人にキュンとする年齢なのかなぁと
思ったりなるほどですね
なチャンね今誰をいいと思っている感じ
読み綺麗な方ですねいいますかん
変
[音楽]
赤青白すごい良くて a で話ですごい
楽しいんですよねうんんで付き合いたい
ですよ
にょもうほんとにちょっと高度にょデート
たくさんしたいっって量すごい好きなん
ですよね温泉3日間
キックれるんだよ熱量がずっとたなぁ
さーああああ
ふぅ
f
んでしょ
はガセいけないですかなんか
twitter を
じゃあ
ちょっとはいろいろあるのでお料理し
ましょうありますパン言われ
ね
いいと思います
ブーバー
死ぬ
[音楽]
いるスタイルました
のかーっ
やるぽん
いやくらいから着付け入ってもらったよな
んですけどさっきましょう
にしていたuse
ブーブー外相からですよそれじゃない気が
する
よ
[音楽]
わせ
なくてベッドに来たまわれ雑貨ずっと来て
ですよ
hey
変わってない楽しいでしましたと言ったと
言われてくれこれは混ぜてないって感じだ
しての靴を出しましたけど
本当に繰り出します
そう
をてやれ恋花摘んでくるっ
重質だから
頑張れマッチますよ
高いクラス e
5試合すっちなみズレすぎだろいい
23ある先月童貞卒業しますいくためにも
これ
ています
見てなかっ思います
サブウェイ道がわからないんです川越妙観
ネットカバーをがなくてゆくないです
ねはしてないよぷっ
はそれじゃあ
卵変でしょあーいると思うよこれがいいね
どこに多分最後掲げた人ができる
やるぞ
ネスレのか知って
[音楽]
でっ
市カフェで会った後にた上で
や意味わかんねーんだよ
折れた枝から我々は乗り合い我々
ん見たを着せる
それを食いたくねぇ
俺はいいけど
よろ方急いで言い出したよねー
キャッチーなやる言って
ね
ブーブー
sore
ja
えええっ
そういうのでますね
いや位られますかエナジー
所神社で言って悪事ですよ
いやー
どこでしたか今ほとんどこれですたいかー
いやーちょっとやブサエちゃんの気持ちを
考えたらいたたまれないです
ふざけすぎだぞ
なんだなんださぁつかあればじゃあみんな
やっぱ料理いたんですかねふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇ日ですあったけどあれ
じゃないです
始め子達をずっと言って言ってますねこれ
は誰ですねいやーちょっと究極のがいい
ゴッチさんもただでさえ顔色はれる醤油
飲んでましたっっ心配になりますよ
うんまだね珠帆の頭ではれ降りぐらいは
笑ってましたよね大都市圏としてネチっ
ぽいのって何違うんですね
なんか私本気で最初真剣に見てたんです
けど聞く何かあっこれれ番組に出てみたい
なあってこのおりたリングかしてみたい
などで普及ぷしたりあーあ今がいいとか
げっそのアプローチはとかすぐ言いたかっ
たんだけどプロじゃないよいやからボーイ
一生懸命やってるんだよねちょっと僕見て
by 不安になっていった
ブーブにみんな
てぃ前回はですねちょっと
ブーブーことで打っ統一感って結構みんな
もちっちゃいに移しやすいからとってです
かねはいじゃあいませんそれはやっぱりか
やんテクニック次第かもしれないと思い
ますけどねしかったいない私かでも同じも
のってドイツしたらそれぞれの色がまた
絶対かうんするかもしれないですねまだ
チャンスあると思います
あいまんとこないですよチャンスも5一人
では頑張ってもらいましょう今
すごい絵が入った俺ですいいme
足ファソへの好きなんだよ
必要に
か疎い私は広くちゃレース posted
なろう
ダイエッツ
me
近所たどぅん
上げますお願いします
ブーブーじゃあよしないでしょ
をキムさん
yoshiki さんから愚痴です女の子
の目を見て相手の話をよくチキよく笑え
自分はほとんどしゃべらなくてよしという
ことでこれめちゃくちゃ
ド直球を持ってピクニックじゃううん重厚
そうですね一番モテる男性ができる
ちかちやこっちサント家サーベイまだ目を
合わすことはこれできて土師家ちょっとだ
これを機にぜひマスターしてもらえてんだ
から yoshiki さんいいよとパ
僕は何か line してますやる思い
ます
どう昔
year
大丈夫しています魔女いつもしていること
です魔神
してる
本当にそうしてるよ俺人のリスク読む
入っていますん
おっ
んじゃん
[音楽]
します
クラッチって訳じゃない
てあげます
うん
なにこれ善意
本当に
言い方があっ
深琴でてその味教えるかもしれん
味美味しい黒
はっはっはっん
ずん何かたいっ
can
今は足を味わった光
ウィッチェリー
温め方んですよ
ございます4
やった古書
うん
道木場4番だ上がってるよああ
月きりにゃでしてるんですけどね言えるぞ
ねっ
入らせ買ってみる
ああ
みんな院生黙っちゃってるね皆川元ミス
テーマ日本にもしですけど
抜けヴェルヌ
ん
深いですか
どうでしたが今の考えることができないの
かなあってどうやったらその持っててくる
ニックにつながるのかなって
文字のままをじゃんっツナは何だろうなっ
て言うけど
でもさー
この口がうなって部誰かが支えていかない
とずっとこのままだよんですかねほら映像
舌からねだよ姉ちゃん強かったと思う
途中から笑顔も消えてますかただ消えれば
消えるほど4人がその江戸を吸ったかの
ように笑っててやっぱ
なにこの映像
馬鹿の一つ覚えるとまさにその通りでいい
ますか平敷さんのアドバイスとしては
すごくねーその情報的なこれをやっておけ
ばじゃないっていうものだったのにやあ
ちょっとくゆのストアが残る結果にはなっ
てしまいましたけれども
悔しくもない
呆れてますバン米ありますかこれからへ
へいへいは結果発表ですねー
ブーバー
しっなやっぱやちゃんがやっぱり選ぶとし
たらだけだと思うあーじゃあね選ぶとし
たらこんちさんツーショットですごい良い
感じに可能盛り上がってたのに醤油のんだ
けどなんかそういうのでもそれでたんです
が下がっちゃったぁー
ng ですこれほど遊んじゃいけません
正解ですだからやっぱ総合的にずっと
明るく会話を引っ張った圭介さん e 賞
で残ってるのかもしれないよでちゃった
スザクもなぁ人のポスト食べるカラーっっ
よくライありゃ来ないねぇちなみにや畑や
田にバースト1円を決めてもらっているん
ですけれどもこれ見に切っさん的に誰だ
ファーストカー
くるすいなぁ
な
3エリアしちゃうっ
キターずっとよろしい目でピンチでは
ふぉとわーく移送人
女の子その敏感だからもしかしたらちっ
いやらしい顔してたっていう
というわけでちょっと
哲也との
受験生にしかも時になると思うんですよ
ありがたくているように戻しましょうは
上を向いてるなぁ
北へ目ちゃってる
どうしたの
どうしたなう
見直しました
ああもうチェックをろくにちゃって言葉で
何か
1003と今日を初してみてどうでしたか
ん
れるぞ
なるほどな楽しかってます
楽しかっ
人生どうぞセッション2回ことなんつて
じゃあせした
ありませんグッズさんはどうでした
一緒だから応援します
そういうわけで
この企画はちょっと残酷な部分もあるん
ですけども
白ちゃんに
ブーバーシンパ
だ5位と
ビリを決めてほしいですわかりますから
みんなどっちーからいきますか大会に入る
はい
では皆さん
おひさを言ってをメジャー国交の感じでは
基金としますねー
くださいじゃんん頑張りましたから
やりがい
ちょっとちょっとちょっと気になっ
どう
year
ああああああああああああ
もう
これは何を切る尺ねなぜかいい話が降って
くれたですねはいこれだけ高
5お花2でくるしきーあーありがとう
分かっ
なりいうか全然ってやってくれ仲良い奴
どうやったんですよ service さん
まああーくそ
4よかったんですけど魔女役会はが大事か
なと思っていまあ
じゃあよかないやたあーんだよーきゃな
あー
よかったよい子
ようなもみ爺パーチョコビを食べてる画像
かとりわけ大会でした者さんや year
さあ
3値は平気でしちゃうください
では続いてはありますよブーブれそう
dejiああああああああまだわかんない
けどなかなかまだわからないねでは
日の人を得られる際
まーすとですね
ああああ
ブーブー言っ
理想の話してるんだまあよく時と全然逆
ないでほしいとかなんかパーカーニー
ソ
はしだから
もうチューブ違うなぁと思って
ブーバー
し
はいえーつかあっ
位以下
rean
ふっ切っ
ニっ
ねよねーちゃんが圭佑を選ぶっていうなん
となくビリーさん言った感じなのかなって
いう気がしましたねパリずば抜けて空気を
読んで場を盛り上げるトーク力が健介バレ
ましたじゃないなぁてる男の子っていう
感じがうーんどれだけありましたね振り子
ナース盛り込んだ質問からの好きな色って
なんかこんな空気になるのかなーと思って
たんですけど
ちょうどいい感じに行ってたなーっていう
しかにが他が3人だとちょっとなんかどう
なってたんだろうと思うございますけどね
まーす額はもうちょっと女の声からしたら
ちょっと子供だなーっていうねとりあえ
体操と違ってくるなっちゃうんだろうか
なぁ
ました
スタント触ればちょっとやりすぎてたら
うんちょっと慣れて出すいいビュー感は
ありましたねもっとリードして欲しかった
と思いますこれはれの時とか良くも悪くも
鍵は薄かったんですねやすくさあまあ
すごいよかったんですよアドバイスとし
たらゲームで見てたんですよね
分かったも皆
ねえねえ浮いてる分では楽しかったですけ
どーってぱねぇテクニックとしては
ちょっと苦味撮り方が違ってたんですね
やしきさんがこれをやったらきっと女の子
はすごい自分に興味を持って聞いてくれて
るって覚えたと思うんですけどちょっと4
人の
回力のなさから夫婦んこは変だ村の晩餐会
に迷い込んじゃったらなーみたいな家は
いえ食事会って何ですか
もったいなかったですねいいアドバイス
勝ったと思ったっていうそういう連市場の
番組見たら実際に映像もあると思うんで
実戦に打ちやすいような気がしますねぇ
うん彼主だとやっぱり女性のゲストが
すごく女の子目競ってが依頼された時
嬉しかったとかいやそうじゃないとかって
いうのニュー草てやってるからこれやり方
勉強ああっを張ったり車としてはすごく
今回の徹夜はそこに胴塚女性心分かって
ますかねあ
でーしょん見てもらいますどうぞござい
ます一緒にで言ってくださいしますいやー
もう涙なしでは見られない感動の
エピソード番でした a ありがとう
ございました23図解潜ってるやってる
もうちょっといいですかいい感じの後輩
えええっそれ行けっ正直彼を染めちゃった
米だなぁああああああああ
ブーバー本日コラボしたニューヨーク練習
場は毎週火曜日の夜11時から雨まで放送
中でございます今回ですね一致だった計付
の入力しますテクニックなんですけれども
番組ではほかにもたくさんの恋愛
テクニックが紹介されておりますので是非
皆さんご覧くださいとしてなんと12月の
28日にはスペシャル企画も多そうされ
ます峯岸さんもご出演されていた
デザイナーの人気格であるん厚手程度に来
て来られたらいいやな服ああああアレです
ねコスプレ面白いめちゃくちゃで今度は
そちらの冬服で放送予定ですので皆さん
是非ご覧ください番組の詳しい内容は動画
概要欄からチェックできますのでみなさん
ぜひこれ見て男性も女性もモテてください
はいというわけで23どうですか恋愛に
慣れてない4人の男の子たちが
テクニック駆使しながら
多少成長した姿が見られてはい皆でもてて
いきたいですね確かにそのないまた
エピソード2でお会いしましょう
さようなら
あっは
[音楽]
blr